nous équipes sont allées demander aux
français ce qu'il pensait justement de
ces vaccins écouter leur réaction au
micro de nicolas coupé ja d'une part je
trouve que ça fait pas assez longtemps
enfin pour avoir un vaccin efficace je
pense
on sait très bien qu'il faut des années
des années pour savoir si vraiment
quelque chose d'efficace et
personnellement je ne compte pas le
faire même si il est bientôt prêt je
suis pas pour les vaccins comme ça je
préfère laisser parler mon corps et
faire voilà qui se défendre tout seul je
préfère au plus possible de ne pas les
fermer
si véritablement il y à une bombe
résultats et au napa aucun souci avec
pourquoi pas je pense pas qu'on puisse
vacciner un seul coup il faut produire
les vaccins donc d'abord vacciner les
sujets à risque parce que ça donne
et ensuite on verra
oui mais j'attendrai j'ai moi
j'attendrais véritable assise du pasteur
déjà